bonjour eric tricot merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france quelle
est la situation de votre côté on c'est
vrai qu'il n'ya pas beaucoup de
reportages dans les hôpitaux dont on a
du mal à se rendre compte de ce qu'il
s'y passe avez vous senti une baisse
sensible du nombre de personnes qui
arrivent à l'hôpital
non on n'a pas senti une baisse sensible
de deux patients qui arrivent
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il ya de plus en
plus de patients parce que les tests se
généralise on a de plus en plus de
patients qui sont commis de plus pour
autant est ce qu'ils font les formes
graves ou pas ça effectivement je suis
d'accord avec vous s'attendrait à ce
style est un petit peu derrière on
essaie de mettre tout en oeuvre pour
répondre à cette éventuelle deuxième
vague qui devrait arriver quand je vois
dans votre introduction tous ces gens
qui sont ensemble
le masque ouais on voyait bien sûr que
ça fait réagir cette fait réagir parce
que on est sur des chiffres il ya 24 ou
48 heures on avait un nombre de décès
qui était quand même assez conséquent et
elie dépassé la barre des 800 qui
correspondait aux premiers chiffres que
l'on avait lors de la première vague
avec un compliment qui est des général
et qui était totale là on est soit un
confinement au chaud crois qu'on peut
même pas appeler sera le confinement
dans les rues effectivement on s'en rend
pas bien compte en tout cas ben nous on
constate on constate en tant que
soignant parce que quand on vient
travailler et quand on voit arriver des
patients
c'est le premier conseil c'est le
premier reflet ses premiers échos en
tout cas que l'on a ce sont les
collègues qui travaille aux urgences il
qu'ils nous le disent très ouvertement
ils nous disent mais à écouter nous le
nombre de patients qui vient tous les
jours il est conséquent il est de plus
en plus il est en hausse et
malheureusement on voit bien que le
confinement
mais ce sont les passions ce sont des
passions qui viennent pour pour des
problèmes de respiration chronique bel
avantage de ces tests qui s'est
généralisé c'est que on a une prise en
charge qui est beaucoup plus précoce que
n'a été lors de la première vague et on
le voit bien là
doctrine de soins qui a été est statué
qu'elle était en tout cas élaboré dans
les réanimations elle est beaucoup
beaucoup moins agressive et vas-y tout
cas n'a été lors de la première réaction
la première vague par an donc oui les
patients arrivent avec beaucoup moins de
détresse respiratoire dixit les échos
que nous on a en tout cas par le rôle
relayé par les par les médecins mais par
contre il faut la forme aura qu'ils font
quand même une forme de crâne qui est
quand même assez atypique quoi générer
dont on arrive quand même à travailler
correctement
par contre ce qui va nous met en
difficulté ce qui nous met déjà en
difficulté c'est moi j'entends les
annonces de ce gouvernement qui dit on a
le capacités on va augmenter le nombre
de leaders et là c'est ce qu'a promis
mais tellement les différents et il veut
augmenter là on est à cinq milles il
faut les augmenter à cette nuit on sait
pas quand est-ce que ce sera fait en
tout cas c'est une promesse oui alors ça
c'est une promesse mais depuis
maintenant depuis six mois on est
habitué à voir des promesses qui ne
tiennent pas la route
non par contre ce qui nous inquiète
c'est vous pouvez mettre tous les lits
que vous voulez les transformer en lit
de réanimation
moi je fais cette métaphore avec vous
pouvez mettre la plus belle le plus beau
des camions la plus belle des voitures
si vous mettez pas de chauffeur est là
mais pas de voiture va restaurer lâche
le problème c'est qu'on a pas de
personnel
quid du personnel moi quand j'entends un
à présent capable de dire que en quinze
jours il a formé 7000 soignants je sais
pas comment il fait pour faire un
infirmier spécialisé tel que je suis il
me faut 5 ans minimum d'école avec deux
ans d'expérience professionnelle pour
faire un médecin anesthésiste
réanimateur c'est plus de 12 ans qu'il
faut c'est pas ça se fait en quinze
jours donc on voit bien que là ils ont
un renfort avec les étudiants qu'ils
soient médecins ou les étudiants
paramédicaux
mais ce sont des gens qui ne sont pas
formés du tout c'est pas des
professionnels aguerris tels que nous
nous sommes ce soit des infirmiers qui
ont l'habitude de travailler en
réanimation ou les infirmiers
d'anesthésié et de réanimation que nous
sommes qui travaillons aussi bien en
esthétique
dans l'animation mais les médecins
réanimateurs on parle des équipes qui
pourraient être mieux dispatcher
pardonnez moi cette expression vous êtes
d'accord avec ça non absolument pas on
est déjà conforté à une démographie
médicale
depuis les années ce qui explique une
des causes des déserts médicaux en
france où il va aller chercher ces
médecins lester young tous ces médecins
réanimateurs il va les prendre par les
retraités mais c'est les gens qui ont
travaillé excessif aux montants qu'ils
se sont épuisés au travail qui sont
rincés et vous allez les remettre dans
une situation compliquée que
l'anesthésié ou la réanimation
donc la seule solution est de ralentir à
l'est les entrées et donc de de confiner
pour moi la seule solution est effectif
pour moi seule solution c'est un
confinement
un vrai confinement alors ça implose ça
à la pause par dont une vraie discipline
des concitoyens français il faut enfin
moi je suis choqué honnêtement on est
tous et je me fais le porte parole des
personnels soignants
on est tous choqués c'est ce qui nous
avait heurté lors de la première vague
c'est de voir tous ces parisiens et tous
ces jeunes qui a été autour du bassin de
la villette et qui saperait le champagne
mais si vous avez un masque s'il avait
un masque est ce que vous seriez choqué
et également parce que dehors s'est
avéré moins contagieux que quand on est
enfermé dans un câble a cependant c'est
ce qu'on entend c'est ce qu'on entend
dire ben je suis d'accord avec vous
effectivement faudrait avoir des masses
mais encore une fois il faut avoir
peut-être aussi une stratégie économique
relocalisation des entreprises qui
fabriquent les matches qui n'ont pas
d'armes à des basques pardon et non pas
les faire faire à l'étranger parce que
la demande avait la demande mondiale ou
en tout cas wendel serait ce que la démo
leur rappellera pas tellement été
importante qu'on va se retrouver de se
retrouver en pénurie et c'est pas c'est
pas le sou elle a pour l'instant on
n'est pas à flux tendu on a des
capacités en matériel pour faire face
mais pendant combien de temps il faut là
pour le coup il faut il fois dans le
préventif
fouette il faut en tout cas objective et
une deuxième bague qui risque d'être
beaucoup plus importante que la première
et et voire même une troisième
on parle même plus de seconde vague on
parle de deuxième vague j'en sais rien
je suis je suis pas devin je ne peux pas
lire dans une boule de cristal
les laissait la glace alors tant qu'il
ya pas de vaccin je suis là quand des
coups mais ne serait ce que dans la
prévention
si on fait un parallèle avec la grippe
espagnole de la première guerre mondiale
c'est la deuxième vague qui avait été la
plus meurtrière là on se dirige vers une
deuxième pack c'est un virus qui édite
saisonnier donc on rentre de plain pied
dans cette saison où les virus ont
commencé à se propager
écoutez j'ai un voisin qui rendent de du
cac a pris la bio dernièrement et il me
dit c'est incroyable on arrive à
l'aéroport
il n'y a pas de ça s'il n'y a pas de
filtre ya rien du tout c'est je
l'entends des députés qui disent ou des
mères même de jeu face et maire de nice
qui lisait il faut il faut refermer les
frontières de l'espace schengen mais il
faut jouer le jeu je crois que c'est
c'est même si et c'est choquant ce que
je vais dire même s'il n'ya eu que
quarante mille morts qui sont déjà pour
moi trop 1 seulement et déjà deux trous
et voilà mais il faut se donner les
moyens de l'objectif que l'on peut là
pour l'instant on est souvent une
communication qui est qui qui n'est pas
rassurant pour le grand citoyen français
est clair c'est pas clair et c'est pas
rassurant
voilà après faut pas trop infantile il
faut pas non plus être utilisés je ne
dis pas qu'il faut être utilisé les
citoyens français mais le citoyen
français si on lui dit la vérité sont
usés les choses clairement il va se
prendre en main il va être se
discipliner là on est dans le petit peu
dans le grand n'importe quoi
ce qui était à l'origine de la première
gbagbo si vous en avez des communicants
de ce gouvernement qui vous lisent est
le bas ce qui n'était pas adapté qu'il
faut pas le mettre dans la rue il
fallait pas le mettre en société il
fallait pas le mettre devant tout le
monde il fallait laisser ça aux
professionnels voilà c'est c'était en
été dans le grand n'importe quoi
là on a l'impression qu'on ne se sert
pas d idée de ce qui s'est passé donc
lors de la première vague et on
recommence voilà sauf que les deux
clusters principaux liés à la première
vague était l'île de france est la
france
est ce là tous les clusters fleurissent
de partout ça flambe de partout sur le
territoire national donc il faut il faut
que les citoyens prennent comprennent
que nous n'aurions pas leur fort ni
médicale ni paramédical donc ils doivent
nous faire preuve d'une solidarité
envers les personnels soignants et bien
il va plus loin d'applaudir à 20 heures
il n'y va plus parce que malheureusement
ils sont pas mulhouse accompagné corrida
il a fallu porter haut et fort nos
revendications en juin là maintenant il
faut jouer le jeu on rentre de plain
pied dans la dent dans l'hiver il faut
on sait pas ce que ça va donner en
sortie l'hiver et il faut qu'on soit
beaucoup plus disciplinés merci beaucoup
électrique aux messages reçus est resté
bien disciplinées et respectées les
gestes barrière quelles que soient les
endroits merci en tout cas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce soir sur rt
sens